we have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two, David p.
Uh, and today's voicemail is once again this
nonsense type of thing about, uh, David will
you, will you trash Sam Cedar?
Will you trash some other hosts?
But it's actually kind of a funny one and
it might even be tongue in cheek.
So let's take a listen to it.
Hey Peter, his career, his resume, he's in
the pocket of big city, big cause burgers.
Mark Marin, you're saying you think he's innocent
actor like yourself or you didn't even, you
know, big corporate office and talk to these
big corporate meeting crown corporations.
I just want to know you're answering this.
All right.
I have a nice day.
Okay.
Yeah.
So listen, if that's tongue in cheek, if that
satire, going back to this entire thing of
Oh, a tattle on Sam seed or tattle on David
Pakman to Sam seat or get this host to attack
that host, if it's satire is very, very clever.
If it's serious, seek help is my only answer.
On today's bonus show, we will talk about,
uh, Congressman Duncan Hunter using campaign
funds for his personal sexual affairs.
According to prosecutors.
We will talk about San Francisco banning the
sales of e cigarettes, and we will also talk
about some billionaires who have made what
to some people is a surprising requests to
the 2020 Democratic candidates.
The billionaires that are saying, tax me more,
put more taxes on me as a billionaire because
we believe it would be good for the economy.
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show, two ways to get access to the bonus
show.
They both are instant access and take under
a minute.
Okay.
Number one, become a member@wwwdotjoinpacman.com
number two, become a patron at patrion.com/david
Acne.
Look forward to talking to you on the bonus,
the David Pakman show@davidpakman.com.